Gestern Abend bin ich mit dem Auto gefahren und ich hatte das Podcast-Ufo an. Keine äusseren Einflüsse, keine anderen Dinge, nur das Podcast-Ufo. Hallo, guten Tag, herzlich willkommen zur neuen Ausgabe, das Podcast UFO 425. Schön, dass ihr mit dabei seid.
Mit Flobel und Stefftiz. Richtig, zwei Menschen. Eine Nase. Eine Nase, richtig, ja. Wir haben uns die Nase operieren lassen und wir haben uns dieselbe Nase geteilt. Wir konnten uns nicht einigen da in der Klinik, wir wollten beide die gleiche Nase haben und dann meinte der Arzt, ihr könnt auch einfach dieselbe Nase haben. Jetzt haben wir zwei grosse, also Monolöcher. Jeder hat quasi die Hälfte dergleichen, derselben, nicht dergleichen, derselben Nase bekommen. Und wir, manchmal glaube ich, das stört. Ich habe immer gedacht, das stört, weil die Nase, da wäre ja viel mehr Loch, wenn ja nicht diese Brücke dazwischen wäre. Ja, das stimmt. Da hätte man so ein riesen, wie so ein mundgrosses Loch noch im Gesicht, zumindest wegen Auge. Vor allem das ist ja nur fake, das geht ja nur ein Zentimeter rein, die Teilung, oder? Danach trifft man sich. Das ist doch wie das Zweiparteien-System in den USA. Das ist doch oberflächlich nach außen ein Unterschied. So ist doch die Nase eigentlich auch letzten Endes, dass es doch keinen Unterschied macht. Deswegen, du hast die rechte Seite, ich habe die linke Seite, das heißt, wenn wir uns jetzt innig küssen, ist die Nase endlich, endlich, endlich nicht mehr im Wege. Aber wir dürfen uns natürlich beim Küssen nicht bewegen, also nicht rotieren. Wir müssen kerzengerade uns beide auch in die Augen gucken, wir gucken uns beim Küssen, das linke Auge guckt in ein rechtes, rechtes in die linke. Nicht den Fehler machen, die Augen zuzumachen beim Küssen.
Auf gar keinen Fall, dann weiss man ja nicht, wann du das Zeichen gibst für den Salto.
Exakt, weil für den Zungensalto oder für den echten Salto.
Okay, weil das war so ein Intro, wo ich dachte, ich wünschte, es wäre länger.
Weil ich hatte das Gefühl, die Künstlerin hat uns noch ein bisschen was zu sagen.
Ich dachte erst, sie will hinleiten, dass sie geblitzt wurde.
Richtig, deswegen hat man ja diesen Fotoapparat gehört.
Nathalie heißt die gute Dame.
Ja, ich höre das immer nicht so richtig, weil du es auf deinem Laptop
anmachst. Ja, und ein
Jan war auch mit im, ich weiss nicht, ob der
gefahren ist, ob der im Rücksitz
saß oder im Kofferraum. Mit einer Gießkanne, das kann man sich
ganz einfach vorstellen, der lag da rum.
Wir haben ein Schaubild hochgeladen auf gieskanne.de, der offene Gieskanfall.org.
Slash gieskanne.jpeg.
Da ist ja noch einiges offen, es sind ja noch viele Fälle offen.
Richtig, wir erwarten noch eine Mail von Michael slash Matthias.
Michael ist jetzt erstmal abgetaucht oder hat sich unbedingt in Matthias und die Mails werden automatisch gefiltert. Wir haben Matthias-Filter drin seit einigen Wochen, mit dem wir beide sehr zufrieden sind. Wir probieren seit Monaten, das wisst ihr nicht, das geht hier nicht mit, weil vieles läuft hier im Hintergrund. Ein Podcast, ihr denkt immer, ihr kriegt viel mit. Nein, die meisten Sachen passieren im Hintergrund. Wir probieren immer verschiedene Spam-Filter aus, damit wir nicht überflutet werden mit Nachrichten. Jetzt haben wir seit einer Zeit einen Matthias-Filter drin. Und um 80 Prozent weniger Traffic.
Ich habe seitdem, ich weiß nicht, wie es dir geht, aber ich kann wieder sehr gut schlafen. Ich ernähre mich gesünder. Ich schwitze kaum noch. Ich habe immer so eine herrliche Kühle. Da hast du zu sagen, ich schwitze mehr. Ja, okay, gut. Also ich schwitze hier aus irgendeinem Grund sehr viel mehr. Hier, an genau diesem Ort. Ich weiß nicht, ob das an den kosmischen Strahlen liegt, an der neuen Himmelslupe, die jetzt gebaut wurde von unserer ach so tollen Regierung, die ja gesagt hat, wir müssen nicht den Klimawandel nicht allgemein verhindern, sondern die Verteilung ändern. Es soll einen Ort geben, an dem es ganz heiß ist, damit es an den anderen Orten warm ist. Ich habe das alles verstanden. Ich habe gedacht, die wirtschaftlich stärkeren Länder nehmen sozusagen, weil die es ja mit Geld ausgleichen können, das Opfer auf sich und dann kommt die Himmelslupe und wir werden in Laufheim. Und wir verbrennen Afrika einfach, wie eine erbärmliche Ameise, wird einfach die gesamte Hitze dorthin geleitet. Anscheinend wird die gerade noch gebaut und aktuell landet die Hitze direkt auf mir. Das heißt, der Schweiss rinnt mir vom Gesicht, die richtige Furchenbildung, ich darf nicht lachen, ich darf nichts machen, weil dann sonst die Wasserströme verändert werden. Da gibt es natürlich Erosion auch, die bilden dann immer so Kringelwege, die dann wieder durchbrechen für gerade. Also es ist eine ganz komplette Erdkunde-Stehgreifaufgabe spielt sich da ab auf meinem Gesicht mit diesen ganzen Wassermassen, die irgendwo hin müssen. Aber wie Doktor Ian Malcolm in Jurassic Park ja gut erklärt hat, ist, wenn du ein Tropfen über die Hand fliessen lässt und dann noch einmal, dann wird ein ganz anderer Weg eingeschlagen. Das könnt ihr mit euren Schweissperlen schön beobachten, wenn du denkst, ah, ich habe den Strom ausgemacht, der genau in mein Auge fließt und du wischst den weg. Nein, der nächste wird auch wieder genau in dein Auge fliessen. Chaos, it's Chaos. Chaos Theorie.
Ich habe mir so einen Cut machen lassen, so oft in die Augenbraue.
Da habe ich mich immer gefragt, ist das natürlich passiert oder macht man da den Regier? Nein, das habe ich tatsächlich so machen lassen.
Leider ist das jetzt wirklich wie eine Regenrinne für Schweiss und es wird jetzt alles komplett direkt in mein Auge reingeleitet.
Aber Mode ist natürlich auch zum Leiden da.
Mode zeigt ja an, ich kann leiden.
Ich habe ein so gutes Leben, ich laufe absichtlich in ganz unbequemen Schuhen, weil es mir so gut geht, dass ich das dann auch noch ... Mode muss immer leidend sein. Ist Kunst immer, weil man sagt, der Form follows function. Du sagst, Design ... Ich sag, pain follows money. Wer viel Geld hat, kann sich viel Schmerz leisten. Du sagst Design. Ich sag Pain follows money.
Wer viel Geld hat, kann sich viel Schmerz leisten.
Du sagst Art follows pain.
Ja, pain follows life.
Das ist eine Ausstellung.
Es ist alles aber ein grosser Kreis am Ende.
Also alles folgt sich gegenseitig und wir haben einen grossen Kreis, der sich ständig im Kreislauf dreht und unser Leben antaucht quasi wie ein grosses Wasserrad.
Perpetuum mobile. Ja, in letzter Instanz schon. Wie viel Hoffnung machst du dir auf den diesjährigen Physik-Nobelpreis? Ich habe ja gehört, aktuell gibt es nicht allzu viele gute Kandidaten, wenig Konkurrenz. Also mein Agent hat mir gesagt, Florentin, wenn dann jetzt. Also jetzt ist jetzt gerade eine Schwäche, eine Flaute in der allgemeinen Physik, jetzt mit Relativitätskonstanten und so haben wir ja das meiste dann auch abgehakt. Ich bin Schauspieler, Moderator, Podcaster. Ich weiß, Florentin, ich weiß, aber kommen gerade aktuell halt nicht so viele Rollen rein. Deswegen dachten wir uns, und ist ja nur ein Angebot, ne? Also jetzt, wir sagen nur, jetzt wäre ein guter Moment. Mir gefällt, dass du hinterher bist, dass du aktiv bist, dass du auch mit proaktiven Vorschlägen kommst. Obwohl ich dir explizit gesagt habe, dass du nicht mit proaktiven Vorschlägen kommen sollst. Ja, ich weiss, aber ich glaube manchmal das Gefühl, dass du gar nicht weisst, was du alles sein könntest. Also du bist so wenig von dem, was du sein kannst. Ich bin Trauspieler. Ich bin Moderator. Ich bin Improviser. Ja, aber da kommt halt gerade nicht viel rein. Ich bin Podcaster.
Da kommt halt gerade gar nichts rein. Der Podcast ist klasse.
Der Nobelpreis. Stefan ist klasse.
Ja, da müssen wir auch noch drüber reden, aber der Nobelpreis, da kriegst du halt einfach mal
zippi zappi 70.000 Euro bar auf die Kralle. 70.000 nur?
Ja, na sicher. Und dafür mal so ein bisschen forschen, das kriegst du doch hin. Kriegt man für den Nobelpreis nicht eine Million Dollar? Ich glaube, das war die Fields-Medaille. Okay. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Pulitzer-Preis ist nicht der Nobelpreis. Aber ich will mal irgendeinen Preis einfach mal haben, das kann doch nicht sein. Einfach mal so einen Preis in der Hand und dann muss ja da auch was dahinter stehen. Einfach da am Buffet stehen und am Ende einfach gewinnen. Ich habe jetzt bei so einer, das ist sehr lustig übrigens, weil ich dachte, ich bin jetzt von der Muse, von Gott geküsst, ich bin ein Glückspilz, weil es gab ein Strassenfest und da war ein Stand der Kölner Haie, die Eisfockey-Mannschaft Kölner Haie und die hatten ein Glücksrad Und da waren sehr viele Möglichkeiten, also es gab nur ein Feld, da konnte man einen Puck gewinnen oder einen Schal, konnte man sich aussuchen, und der Rest der Felder waren Nieten. Jeder konnte einmal hin. Es waren so hundert Felder. Die Chance, dass man da reinkommt, ist nicht gering. Ja, oder ... So ein riesiges Rad. Ja, er war schon gross, aber wahrscheinlich übertreibe ich gerade. Ich habe gehofft, dass du darauf nicht eingehst.
Okay.
So, stellt euch ein riesiges Rad vor mit hundert bis tausend verschiedenen Kästen.
Okay, alles klar. Die Schlange war lang. Wie lang war sie? Wie lang war sie ungefähr? Ein, zwei Kilometer.
Ein, zwei Kilometer.
Das ist ein grosses Strassenfeld.
Das war die grösste Strassen der Welt.
Und dann bin ich vor mir alle mit tränenden Augen davongelaufen, weil es hat nicht geklappt, es hat nicht sollen sein. Ich hin, Dreh dran, es ist knapp, aber dann das Feld der Begierde wird erreicht. Wow, du kannst das so packend und spannend erzählen. Ich stehe da, Ar Arme in die Höhe direkt, jubelnd, Leute applaudieren und dann habe ich gewonnen. Konnte habe ich mir Puk ausgesucht, finde ich cool. Ja gut, kein Schal. Nein, ich habe mich für den Puk entschieden. Aber mit dem Schal kannst du ja deine Lieblingsmannschaft ja unterstützen in der Arena, wenn den Puk. Ja, mit dem Puk auch. Den wirfst du dann einfach aufs Feld ins Tor oder was? Im schlimmsten Fall. Und dann machst du ein Tor für Tietze. Ja, im schlimmsten Fall. Wenn ein Fan, das ist die Regel, nur im richtigen Moment wirft, so das Spiel nicht unterbrochen, so der Schiri nicht gepfiffen, da gibt es jetzt einen kurzen Moment, also sobald der Schiri gepfiffen hat, aber dass der Puck noch nicht angeschlagen wurde. Bevor das Spiel beginnt, ballerst du einen ein. So der Fan richtig geworfen, das Tore soll zählen. Das sprach einst Gandalf. Und seitdem ist das erlaubt. Okay, alles klar. Gut, das heisst, ich bin gespannt, ob du vielleicht die deutsche Meisterschaft um den Eishockeypreis der eiserne Lurch vielleicht tatsächlich dann gewinnst. So, aber man merke, ich habe bereits das gewonnen. Ist der Puck denn ein bisschen elastisch oder ist der Stein steinharter? Härter als gedacht. Härter als gedacht. Im Vergleich zu dem Golfball? Deutlich weicher. Oh. Ja, aber ein Golfball ist richtig hart. Nee, aber ist das das härteste genommen der Welt? Jetzt habe ich das Gefühl,
du hast einen anderen Gedanken.
Weil der Golfball ist super hart.
Ich stelle mir jetzt sehr weich vor, das ist ja wirklich
wie so ein Schaumteigbrötchen.
Wie gesagt, hätte er als gedacht.
Wie so ein Schokobrötchen, dass man den quasi mit der Hand
so zerdotzen kann. So stelle ich es mir gerade vor.
Ich weiss, weil du die falsche Frage gestellt hast.
Das ist mir leider jetzt gerade vorgestellt.
Ja, aber du hast es nicht eingeschränkt, weil du das, die äussere Ende der Skala vergleichst.
Okay, im Vergleich zu Stork Riesen. Weicher. Weicher, okay. Siehste, aber du hast es mir die falsche Frage gestellt. Wie so ein Softball oder so, den man so in der Schule kriegt, den man so ganz ... Super hartes Gummi. Wie so ein Wattebausch im Grunde, oder? Nein, Longboard-Räder. Longboard-Räder, die dir schon massive Verletzungen zugefügt haben, dementsprechend recht hart sein müssen eigentlich. Ja. Okay, ja, dann habe ich jetzt ein Bild. Ich habe deine Wunden noch, ich habe dein Schmerzverzerrter das Gesicht noch vor Augen und kann davon die Härte ableiten. Rief zwei Wochen lang mit so einem Schmerzverzerrten Gesicht herum. Alle dachten, es ist so hell. So, und dann gewann ich also den Puck. Dann war da für alle, für alle Verlierer und den einen Gewinner, in dem Fall ich, gab es dann noch so einen Zettel, wo man sich eintragen konnte fürs Gewinnspiel. Karten gewinnen, Tickets gewinnen. Da durften die Verlierer auch mit. Alle durften mitmachen, alle durften da noch mal reinschreiben. Und dann stellst du dich da zusammen mit den Verlierern hin? Nein, nur die gewinnen, dann stellt man sich da hin. Wenn man gewinnt, die Karten sind jetzt ja auch Gewinner. Weißt du, du wirst ein Verlierer und ein Gewinner. Verstehst du, was ich meine? Aber dem Rat, dem Rat erzeugt Gewinner und Verlierer, die gehen aber beide Ströme, finden sich wieder bei der Anmeldung zum Gewinnspiel. Genau, der Ausgangsstrom geht vorbei am Gewinnspiel. Jeder kann mitmachen, das ist der Trostpreis sozusagen. Jeder darf doch noch mitmachen beim Eintragen. Okay. So, und es gab zwei Tickets zu gewinnen. Wer hat beide gewonnen? Ich. Ich. Kam letzte Woche die Mail. Herzlichen Glückwunsch, Sie haben das Ticket gewonnen. Ja, herzlichen Glückwunsch. Seitdem denke ich, ich kann alles schaffen. Geil, ja, gehen wir hin zusammen. So, und jetzt habe ich bei so einem ... Gehen wir zu zweit hin. Ich habe Zeit. Ja, herzlichen Glück und ... Seitdem denke ich, ich kann alles schaffen. Geil, ja, gehen wir hin zusammen.
So, und jetzt habe ich bei so einem ...
Gehen wir zu zweit hin.
Ich habe Zeit.
Ja, aber ...
Ich liebe Tennis, was, was nochmal?
Eishockey.
Eishockey, ich liebe Eishockey.
Er ist schön kühl.
Das stimmt, das ist wirklich schön kühl.
Perfekter Sport für den Sommer.
Im Sommer wird das ja nicht stattfinden.
Ich kann das ganze Jahr.
Du hast schon jemanden anderen gefragt, nicht wahr? Ja, aber ich dachte, du hast da keine Lust drauf. Du hast selten Lust, dass das... Ja, ich wäre gerne gefragt worden. Um dann abzusagen. Ja, aber ich möchte nicht immer Absagen bekommen. Ja, dann kommen wir hier wohl nicht zusammen. Weil wenn du immer nur absagst, fühl ich mich schlecht. So ist es die Frage. Ja, aber wenn... ich mich schlecht, so ist die Frage. Ja, aber ich will, dass du mir die Aufmerksamkeit gibst, dass du mit mir da gerne hingegangen wärst. Ich geb mit dir überall hin. Aber du willst es nicht. Ich glaube, wir sind anders als unsere Nasen überhaupt nicht kompatibel, Stefan, emotional. Nee, weil das Gehirn ... Ich glaube, wir sind emotional wie so ein Puzzle, wo der Hund einmal alles abgekaut hat und nichts mehr ineinander passt. Wir hätten uns auch für das gleiche Gehirn entscheiden sollen. Können wir uns einigen ... Schreibt mal jeder auf den Zettel, wenn wir uns ein Gehirn teilen müssten, wessen Gehirn sollten wir uns teilen? Von einem lebenden Menschen? Nee, von uns beiden. Wir beide sind ab jetzt in einem Gehirn angeschlossen. Okay. Wessen Gehirn? Ich schreibe mir kurz auf. Ich schreibe es mir auch. Ich tue so, als würde ich es aufschreiben hier auf den Tisch. Ja, okay. Ich schreibe es auch auf. Okay. Und wir lesen es auf der gedachten Null vor. Ja. Drei, zwei, eins, Stefan. Ja. Okay, also können wir uns auch da leider nicht einigen. Gut. Schade. Aber das heisst du, aber hast du denn versucht, diese Glückssträhne fortzusetzen? Richtig. Ich habe jetzt bei einem Gewinnspiel mitgemacht, das wurde mir bei Instagram angezeigt, ein Gewinnspiel. Da konnte man Lose kaufen, habe ich gekauft. Mach ich nicht gerne, aber wie gesagt, ich gewinne ja gerade alles. Über Instagram hast du Lose gekauft. Genau, für ein Gewinnspiel. Ich möchte nicht sagen, was es ist, ich möchte es auch nicht einschränken, dann machen da alle mit. Weil jetzt ist nämlich das Problem, die verkaufen unendlich Lose. Und sie hören nicht auf, dieses Gewinnspiel zu bewerben. Jetzt habe ich ja aber ein deutliches Interesse, das ist eine komische Art Gewinnspiel, finde ich, weil sie klicken ... Der Preis steigt nicht, oder wie? Es gibt immer den gleichen Preis. Es gibt immer den gleichen Preis. Ist es ein Sachpreis? Ja, es gibt eine ... Ist es ein Auto? Nein. Ist es ein Schiff? Nein. Ist es was Lebendes? Nein. Okay, du bist echt knallhart, ey. Du bist wegen dem Dressort. Jetzt hast du es gleich. Jetzt hast du es gleich. Jetzt bist du wirklich drin. Ein Flugzeug? Nein. Irgendwas, womit man sich fortbewegen kann? Irgendwas, das Wert hat? Ja. Fuck. Irgendwas physisch, also ein Objekt? Ja. Es hat was, was mit der Küche zu tun? Grob. Ist ein Haus? Ja. Aha. So, da gab es das Gewinnstiel. Stefan will raus. Weg. Du willst ein Haus? Ich will hier weg. Und aber steht das Haus schon irgendwo? Ja. Also du hast einfach random bei einem Gewinnspiel mitgemacht, wo du schon den Lebensort willkürlich festgelegt hast.
Du hast jetzt ein Haus in Madrid und dann lebst du einfach in Madrid. Das ist auch spannend. Aufgrund dessen, dass es gerade halt ein zum Verlosen erbautes Haus ist, dürfen die aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht sagen, wo es steht. Das heisst, ich habe mich sogar, das ist doch viel schlimmer, ich habe mich auf ein Haus, ich habe bei einer Verlosung eines Hauses mitgemacht, von dem ich nicht genau weiss, wo es steht. Aber hast du zumindest mal die Umgebung gesehen? Oder ist es wirklich wie so ein ausgeschnittenes Greenscreen-Haus? Oder waren Pallen im Hintergrund? waren Strand im Hintergrund? Ich bin kein Geogäster, kein guter Geogäster. Aber ist es in Deutschland? Ja. Ah, okay. Na gut. Ja, aber jetzt ist die Frage, weil was für ein komisches Gewinnspiel, wo unendlich viele Lose jetzt in Umlauf gebracht werden. Verstehst du, was ich meine? Also du, wenn ich ... Die Chance zu gewinnen, das sinkt immer weiter. Für den Einzelnen. Es sinkt immer weiter. Und wenn die jetzt aufhören ... Aber warte mal. Aber wenn du sagst, also gibt es ein Gewinnerlos ja dann, oder? Ja. Das heißt, ab einem gewissen Punkt, wenn jetzt das Gewinnerlos schon verteilt wurde, ist es ja egal, wie viele danach noch teilnehmen. Am Ende wird das ausgelost. Am Ende wird eins von denen zum Gewinnerlos. So, aber wenn du jetzt entscheidest, ich mach auch mit, dann werden quasi neue. Ich schau mal, ob ich's finde, ich schau mal, ob ich mitmache. Neue Lose. Ich schau mal, ob ich mit meinen 12 Fake-Accounts mitmache. Ja, das ist so weird alles. Mathematisch komme ich da nicht hinter, ich bin komplett überfordert, ich hasse es, dass die es immer noch bewerben, ich möchte nicht jetzt erst bewerben, du versuchst es jetzt aktuell sehr schlecht zu machen, du schreibst negative Kommentare, du mailtest es bei Instagram, du versuchst eine Schmieren-Kampagne zu starten mit deinem Fake-X-Account, das heißt du versuchst hier wirklich zu schmieren. Stefan XXX, Herzchen, Herzchen, Herzchen, versuchst du gerade eine Heads-Kampagne zu starten gegen diese Firma, damit die Leute aufhören Gewinnspiele zu betreiben. Exakt, damit zu machen. Weil ich finde es wirklich merkwürdig und ich kenne auch keinen Pondon dazu. In welchem, also wo sonst wird inflationär, bei Bitcoins vielleicht, aber da ist es zumindest am, da richtet sich es am Marktpreis. Also wenn du dann selber noch meinst. Aber ist es nicht bei jedem Gewinnspiel so, dass unter allen Teilnehmern wird dann verlost, wer es kriegt und je mehr mitmachen, desto weniger Chance hat der Einzelne? Als wir Julia Beckers Buch verlost haben, haben wir gesagt, jeder, der ein Buch will, schreibt uns eine Mail. Dann haben wir unter allen eingesandten Mails fünf Gewinnerinnen und Gewinner ausgesucht. Jetzt mussten die sich aber nicht einkaufen. Ach so, du musstest was zahlen, findest. Weil ich gewinne ja gerade alles. Ah ja, ja, okay. Das ist ja keine Rolle. Das ist ein kleiner Preis im Vergleich zum Haus irgendwo in Bottrop. Das ist eine Anzahlung. Das ist wirklich, das kriegt zurück. Investition. Das ist eine Investition. Ja, ich verstehe schon. Aber es ist natürlich jetzt für uns ein bisschen frustrierend, dass wir so lange warten müssen. Also ich hatte auch mal großes Glück in meinem Leben und dann habe ich mir. Wann zuletzt? Das ist schon viele Jahre her, schon viele, viele Jahre her und seitdem, seitdem hatte ich auch kein Glück mehr. Aber zu dem Moment hatte ich richtig viel Glück und dann habe ich mir tatsächlich ein Lotto losgekauft, instant, so ein Rubbel los, so instant los. Alles verloren. Alles verloren. 60.000 Euro Erspartes habe ich verloren, weil ich habe nicht nur nicht gewonnen, sondern da war dann so ein Minus 60 als Preis. Das ist ja, schulden mir jetzt 60.000 Euro Geld. Und glücklicherweise hatte ich noch so viel tatsächlich. Weil du ein Lotto davor gewonnen hast. Seitdem hast du ja gedacht, dass du immer gewinnst. Das war also das ist halt immer null, null. Ne, das war eine Geschichte mit In-Ear-Kopfhörern, aber das ist, die habe ich schon so oft erzählt, das ist jetzt Quatsch. Ich habe Dinge auf der Strasse gefunden, in einer solchen Frequenz, dass ich dachte, ich bin gesegnet, ich bin der Auserwählte, die heiligen Rollen der Ägypter, die gefunden wurden im Grabmal von Tudinich Ammon, reden von mir, war ich, ich bin's, es durchleuchtet. Die lagen lange rum, ja, das stimmt, aber die nimmt ja niemand auf. Ich glaube, du musst die heiligen Rollen des Tudennich Amund nur in so eine zu verschenkten Pappbox tun. Schön Köln-Ports, so eine Strassenecke, wird niemand mitnehmen. Ich glaube, das Bernstein-Zimmer liegt aktuell noch in so einer Zum-Mitnehmen-Kiste
irgendwo und es will einfach niemand mitnehmen.
Aber sag mir, was wurde durchleuchtet?
Der Sarkophag von Tuti nicht Amun.
Jetzt rate mal, was sie gefunden haben.
Eine...
Da fallen so viele doofe Witze ein.
Okay, die
ehrliche Antwort wäre vermutlich
Tuti nicht Amun.
Der ist schon raus.
Wie?
Nur der Sarkophag.
Okay, nichts.
Korrekt.
Okay.
Moment, aber wenn Sie den rausgeholt haben, warum müssen Sie den denn durchleuchten?
Naja, der ist ja recht voluminös.
Du meinst im Rand?
Das ist ja nicht nur eine Klappe.
Ja, der hat ja so eine grosse Maske vorne und alles und da hat man gesagt, lass uns da einfach mal reingucken. Das ist eine andere Idee. Nach 60 Jahren, nachdem sie ihn gefunden haben, durchleuchtet und war nichts drin. Durchleuchtet meinend Infrarot. Man hat anstelle eines krebskranken Kindes, das den Termin hatte für den Kernspintomograph, hat gesagt, setz dich wieder hin, hier kommt Tutelich Amun. Und dann haben die den reingesteckt und haben damit leider den Kernspintomographen zerstört, sodass leider ganz, ganz viele Kinder verenden mussten noch am selben Tag. Aber das ist eben Ägyptologie für dich. Das ist natürlich wichtiger als die aktuellen Lebenden. In der Zeit hatte ich eine wahnsinnig grosse Ägyptenphase. Zu welcher Zeit? So mit sechs. Ach wirklich? Und da hätte ich wahrscheinlich auch den meinen Kernspintomographen hergegeben. Frage, hätte man nicht eines der Kinder in den Sarkophag legen können, oder vielleicht sogar drei, um dann sozusagen alles gleichzeitig zu durchleuchten? Ja. Weil man kann schon noch voneinander abgrenzen. Kann man nicht einfach ganz viele Kinder in einen Sack stecken, die alle gemeinsam in den Kernspintumografen? Jetzt generell meinst du, oder als allgemein? Ich weiß nicht, ob der Sarkophag so eine Klappe hat, dass der nicht mehr aufgeht. Ich glaube, den hat keine so einen Schnapper. Hat er nicht. Das glaube ich auch nicht. Ich glaube, du kommst da locker wieder raus. Ich finde die Idee gut, weil man kann ja vielleicht generell halt Kernspintomographie Zeit sparen, indem man einfach nur zwei Kinder gleichzeitig. Ich weiß nicht, warum wir von Kindern reden, generell Menschen gleichzeitig reinsteckt. Ja, zwei Kinder und dann halt noch irgendein Gemälde oder sowas, was ja irgendwie dann da kann man dann verschiedene Farbschichten oder so. Weil da unterschiedliche Farbschichten sind und dann hat da vielleicht irgendjemand was übermalt, was eigentlich viel besser gewesen wäre. Das ist so Apfel-Z, Apfel-Z der Kunstgeschichte. Was war davor, war das nicht besser eigentlich? Ja, wie viel, wie oft hat sich so Da Vinci gedacht, dumm Vinci und dann so weggestrichen Dinge. Ja, ja, genau. Und dann so neu gezeichnet. Und dann so, ah, jetzt hat es an der Tür geklingelt. Zack, Riesenlinie über das ganze Bild. Oft passiert, ne? Das wäre so, ich mag das. So, das darf ich eigentlich gerne in meinem Buch drüber lesen. Nicht schreiben, nein. Kann jemand anderes das bitte für mich übernehmen? Es ist so nervig, wenn man die Bücher mal selber schreiben muss. Ich weiß. Die grössten Versagermomente der grössten Künstler. So Thomas Mann der... Thomas Mann bei so einem Bingo, Altenheim-Bingo, null Punkte. So wirklich gar null nichts gewonnen. Ich will so Leuten, denen man unterstellt, ein Genie zu sein, bei den grössten Momenten des Scheiterns zugucken. Wirklich, wo der Thomas Mann in der Schule, was ist die Hauptstadt von Frankreich und er sagt Lyon in so einem vergessenden Moment. Und wir sitzen da und lesen das Buch und lachen. Loser! Hätte ich gewusst! Es ist natürlich Genf.
Weißt du, aber sowas, sowas.
Ja, finde ich eine gute Idee, aber natürlich auch Antike, ne?
Tutanchamun, irgendwie war gottsgleicher Kaiser, aber hat irgendwie aus Versehen ein Eukalyptusblatt gegessen statt Salat und hatte drei Tage Durchfall.
So, und dann einfach, ha ha ha, du Trottel, bist du ein Koala, Tutanchoala, Tutanchmun nicht Moen, so die nahen Super-Gags, die man dann abklappern kann. Das finde ich auf jeden Fall wichtig, einfach um sich besser zu fühlen selbst. Ja, oder Cäsar, der so einen Schluckauf hatte bei so einer krassen Rede. Ja, genau. Oder so, weiß ich nicht, Alexander der Grosse, der an den Truppen vorbei geritten ist, um die aufzupeitschen, aber dabei hat er sich ganz doll verschluckt.
Ja, so richtig verschluckt, hat tief eingeatmet, in so einer Sandwüste, richtig gerustet und dann kam auch richtig Schleim mit raus, so richtig Schleim und dann wollte er es so ausspucken, aber der Wind hat es ihm wieder so auf seine Brustplatte. Die haben das die ganze Zeit so rum, aber wegen Autoritätsgebärden haben die ihm dann nicht das sagen wollen. Und der eine Standardenträger hat versucht, so mit seiner Fahne, und er so, nimm die Standard aus dem Munde! Aus dem Wasser, er hat versprochen ein grosses Fumble. Und ja, der Stadt hat Watzim gewonnen. Und er ist einfach zum Feindlichen hergeritten und meinte so, wir machen die fertig, wir bringen die um, und er so, Jeff, das falsche, ach scheisse und dann waren die Gegner total motiviert. So was halt. The big fumbles. Oder Hitler bei Kreuzworträtsel irgendwie, dumm, lustig, mit fünf Buchstaben, albern, hat er nicht gewusst, hat er freigelassen. So, einfach mal so ein paar Zeitungen aus dem Bunker oder so, wo man sagt, Alter, was sind das denn verantwortlich?
Ja, um mal, um mal
sich selber grösser zu fühlen
und die mal so ein bisschen wieder einzuordnen.
Gibt's die Nies wirklich?
Nein. Das ist alles nur ...
Oh, das war jetzt aber sehr schnell, das ging jetzt aber
rapide. Gibt's die Nien?
Aha, okay, weil du hast mir gar keine
Möglichkeit gelassen, zu antworten. Gibt's die Nien?
Ja.
Weil das sind alles nur ... Die Geschichte erzählt man rückwärts. Aber diese Menschen haben ja vorwärts gelebt, dem Scheisse gebaut. Erzähl die Geschichte rückwärts. Ja, man erzählt die Geschichte über die Leute, die am Ende ein geiles Werk hatten. Dann nimmt man sich das Werk und nimmt sich dann die coolen momente die es wert sind zu erzählen und erzählt es rückwärts du würdest niemals die scheiternden momente klar irgendwann ist ein mensch so krass und willst alles darüber herausfinden oder halt ein dicker sarkophag so dass du einfach gefunden wirst zwangsläufig und alle sagen der muss der krasseste sein aber er hat halt einfach nur den dicksten Sarkophag von allen. So, dass einfach einfach gefunden wirst, zwangsläufig, und alle sagen, der muss der krasseste sein, aber er hat halt einfach nur den dicksten Sarkophag von allen. Es kommt nicht auf die grösste Sarkophags an. Sondern auf die dicke. Ja, aber gute Frage, was werden Archäologen und Historiker von uns irgendwann erforschen und durchleuchten? Ob die irgendwann mal bei Stefan sein Sofa, die Mikros durchleuchten, das Sofa durchleuchten? No, bitte nicht. Was kommt da in den Kernspintomographen der Zukunft in hundert Jahren? Was werden die finden? Ich meine, zwei Centstücke. Zum Beispiel, was ist da drin? Nichts. Trottel. Ich glaube, was ein guter, man überlegt ja so, was würde man so, wie könnte man einen Menschen gut kennenlernen in der Zukunft, in 100 Jahren. Und ich habe mir letztens gedacht, was ja eigentlich sehr persönlich und sehr intim ist, sind die auf dem iPhone die Wecker. Snooze. Weil wenn du auf dem iPhone Wecker machst für 8 Uhr, dann wird der gespeichert. Und beim nächsten Mal hast du auch noch 8 Uhr 5 oder 9 Uhr. So und irgendwann, wenn du das iPhone lange benutzt hast, hast du eine ganz lange Liste von Momenten, an denen du schon mal geweckt wurdest. Und manchmal scrolle ich da gedankenträgend durch und dachte mir, ich bin schon mal um drei Uhr nachts aufgestanden. Jetzt schon spannend, weil eine lange Liste für mich schon eine riesen Red Flag wäre. Ah, ich verstehe.
Keine iPhone-Hygiene oder Handy-Hygiene.
Weil wenn jemand ganz viele Wecker drin hat ...
Nee, nee, nee, ich finde, wer ein aufregendes und aktionsreiches Leben lebt, hat ganz viele verschiedene Wecker.
Manchmal stehst du um 8.20 Uhr auf, manchmal um 6.40 Uhr, manchmal um 2 Uhr nachts, manchmal um 14 Uhr.
So ganz viele unterschiedliche Dinge.
Manche sind einfach nur neuer Wecker 18, neuer Wecker 72, manche sind aber einfach Anruf, Ausrufezeichen, Anruf, Ausrufezeichen.
Und ich glaube, da könnten irgendwie in der Zukunft Forscher eine Menge über mich lernen, wenn sie all diese Wecker mal durchgehen. Was ist da alles passiert? Bei mir habe ich jetzt auch gesehen, werden neuerdings auf dem neuen Betriebssystem vom iPhone, werden Timer gespeichert, die man sich gestellt hat, um dann schneller die Lieblingszeiten, die man immer timet, wieder anklicken zu können. Was ist, würdest du sagen, dein durchschnittlicher Timer jetzt auf einmal, dein gesamtes Leben gerechnet, der durchschnittliche Timer? Und was sagt das über dich aus? Also weil ich, wenn ich Sport mache, immer einen Zwei-Minuten-Timer immer für sport für die verpausen ich immer zwei minuten den den man sich so oft dass ich vermutlich dass meine zeit so bei drei vier minuten im durchschnitt läge weil das ist mein timer leben lebt im spannungsfeld zwei minuten und aufbackbrötchen zwölf bis fünfzehn minuten also meistens so vierzehn. Okay. Das ist das Spannungsfeld deines Lebens. Einmal die Hochintensität Spannung, aber dann auch wieder die Aufbackbrötchen.
Ich würde es nicht Hochintensität nennen.
Aber dann auch wieder die Aufbackbrötchen.
Ja.
Bei mir ist es Kartoffeln 15 Minuten, Reis 13 Minuten und jetzt ganz neu, meine Hände sind durch. Man kann da ganz kurz darauf eingehen, dass Kartoffeln 15 Minuten, das ist weird, genau 15 Minuten. Die wissen ja nichts von unserer Zeit, die wissen auch nichts von 100 Grad, Wasser kocht auf 100 Grad. Das Wasser war genau 100 Grad kocht.
Aber meinst du nicht, dass die so gezüchtet werden mittlerweile, dass die genau auf eine runde Zeit genau perfekt durch sind? Aber erst wenn es kocht natürlich, erst in kaltes Wasser rein, dann auf den Herd und dann, sobald es kocht, dann fängt der Timer an. Vergiss ich immer. Da musst du immer dann den Timer erdrücken. Aber jetzt habe ich zwei Minuten Timer für meine Hände sind kaputt. Oh, meine Hände, so seit meinem Urlaub, ich weiß nicht, was da passiert ist, aber ich war ja davor schon lange Gamer, sagen wir mal, und es gab ein Videogame, das habe ich gezockt, Valorant heißt es, ein First Person Ego Shooter, bei dem man seine Hand stark belastet, weil du machst ganz schnelle Bewegungen. Da hast du dann angefangen, dein Fingerträgen zu machen, richtig? So, und da habe ich irgendwann gemerkt, das tut mir weh in der Hand. Und dann habe ich angefangen, Gamer-Handübungen zu machen. Mit dem kleinen Finger. Mit dem kleinen Finger und mit der Hand und alles und so dehnen und so. Bist du weitergekommen damit jetzt? Wir können es ja mal testen. Nein. Also bisschen. Das ist wirklich erbärmlich. Ich weiß auch nicht, ich weiß auch nicht, der, der, der macht nicht mit, der kleine Finger. Der zieht nicht mit und ich habe keinen Bock mehr auf den kleinen Finger und ich habe eigentlich immer eine Übung gemacht und dann ging es auch besser, aber jetzt habe ich Kribbeln in den Händen und muss, mache jetzt Übungen, Stichwort Kapal-Tunnel-Syndrom, habe ich mal so ein bisschen Übungen gemacht und da muss ich jetzt auch immer zwei Minuten lang so, ist an sich ein ernstes Thema, aber viele Menschen haben das tatsächlich, jede fünfte Hand hat das. In jeder fünften Hand? In jeder fünften Hand. Also jeder zweieinhalb der Mensch oder jede fünfte Hand, bei manchen Menschen beide Hände und da muss ich das jetzt machen, da muss ich jetzt drücken, weil meine Hände haben keinen Bock mehr. Also der Kapal, für für alle die es nicht wissen, ich weiss es natürlich, für alle draußen die es nicht wissen, der Karpal-Tunnel ist ein Kanal im Bereich, so Jordaniens, im Bereich der Handwurzel, der durch Knochen und Bindegewebe begrenzt wird. Er liegt an der Innenseite von Handgelenk und Handwurzel und wird von einem festen Bindegewebsband, dem Karpalband, Renitaculum flexorum überspannt. Durch den Karpaltunnel verlaufen Sehnen der Mittelnerv und der Mittelnerv. Also der Karpaltunnel ist so ein bisschen wie der Brenner. So, alle wollen da durch und es gibt ständig Stau, weil da müssen irgendwie die ganzen Nerven durch für alle Finger und dann verschiedene, alle stopfen sich durch diesen kleinen Tunnel durch und da gibt es halt ständig Stau und dann müssen die alle anhalten und deswegen schläfen deine Hände ein, weil da dann glaube ich keine Nervensignale mehr übertragen werden können. So was in der Ecke. Also entweder Rheuma, Diabetes oder halt Krebs. Ja, ich habe mir auch schon selbst und das Verrückte und jetzt habe ich ein bisschen Angst, weil ich hatte das so ein bisschen kribbeln in den Händen. Dann habe ich auch mal gegoogelt natürlich, wie tot bin ich schon, wie lange habe ich noch. Und dann hat jemand geschrieben so, ja, irgendwie meine Tante hat es schon ganz lange und die wacht teilweise in der Nacht auf, weil die Hand komplett eingeschlafen ist, komplett taub und das weckt dich anscheinend auf.
Und da dachte ich mir, okay, krass, so schlimm ist ja bei mir nicht, kein Problem, passt schon. Nächste Nacht, ich wache mitten der Nacht auf, meine linke Hand komplett taub. Ich kann sie nicht mehr bewegen, nicht mehr spüren. Das ist psychosomatisch. Da dachte ich mir, okay, das ist jetzt schon, also das ist unter Medizinern wahrscheinlich so dieses Google, Google Cebo, wo es wahrscheinlich mittlerweile schon einen eigenen Begriff dafür gibt, dass wenn du Symptome googelst, du sie hast am nächsten Tag. Ja, kann ich mir auch vorstellen.
Und da dachte ich mir dann, ja okay, fuck, vielleicht ist es dann doch schon weiter als ich. Keine Angst, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer daraus, ich habe mir schon einen Termin gemacht, ich habe nächste Woche einen Termin beim Handologen, beim Manologen.
Da geht man, du bist jetzt im Hausreist.
Nee, ich gehe direkt zum Handologen.
Manus, Manuel.
Hand direkt Manu.
Geh ich direkt hin. Und jetzt muss ich tatsächlich auch so Übungen machen,
auch zwei Minuten, das ist stark über den
und so. Die hast du schon mitbekommen.
Die hast du im Internet, der googelt auch. Die hab ich jetzt mir selber
auch mal googelt, YouTube. Und es geht auch, läuft einigermaßen,
aber ich mach jetzt schon
Rückenübungen jeden Tag und jetzt mach ich auch noch
Handübungen jeden Tag. Das heißt, falls ein Sarkophag frei ist, ich glaube, ich habe Interesse langsam. Nee, nee, der Durchleuchten-Part, der ist, den du brauchst, glaube ich. Ah, okay, gut, erst mal durchleuchten. Also vielleicht werde ich auch zum Durchleuchten direkt in den Sarg reingelegt und dann sagen, wissen Sie, was er will, Ihre Hände sind so kaputt, bleiben Sie liegen, wir machen den Dec Deckel zu. Dann war es das. Dann machen wir hier Schluss.
Dann singen wir noch alle dreimal Ave Maria. Dann ist es gut. Ja, komm, dann ist ja gut jetzt. Okay? Okay, dann sage ich gut. Komm, dann machen wir zu die Sache. Also ja, ich gehe langsam kaputt. Der Verfall nimmt stetig seinen Lauf. Und ja, bald war es das. Ich habe das Gefühl, weil ich jetzt wieder langsam gesund werde. wir haben so eine, in diesem Raum hier herrscht eine endliche Anzahl Gesundheitspunkte und wir müssen uns die auftalteinander und du zerfällst, während es mir wieder gut geht. Okay, ja, aber ist ja auch fair, dann habe ich jetzt mal eine schlechte Phase. Ich habe aber neulich, ich habe so einen, das ist jetzt, ja, ihr habt kurz einen Hinblick, einen Einblick in so einen darken Punkt in meinem Kopf. Aber ich habe neulich einen jungen Mann mit Krücken gesehen und dachte mir, oh, das will ich auch. Aha. Achso, okay, du willst Krücken haben. Warum? Ich bin nicht stolz auf den Gedanken, weil das tut mir sehr leid und alle, die es nicht können, tun mir leid. Du, wir sind hier völlig offen für alles. Stimmt, wir sind ja hier unter uns. Wir sind ja unter uns. Und wir kriegen ja nie böse Nachrichten oder sowas, aber ich habe wirklich gedacht, boah, ich habe auch echt Bock, mal wieder davor. Aber war es was Sexuelles oder war es was? Krücken, nein, nein, nein. Es war ein reines, ein reiner FOMO-Gedanke. Wie befreiend ist dein Leben, wenn du eben nicht mobil bist? Wie befreiend ist denn eigentlich dein Leben, du kannst ja einfach auf der Couch liegen, du musst nicht zum Sport, du kannst nichts machen und dann fiel mir wieder meine Platte ein, die ich reinbekommen habe auf mein Schlüsselbein, weil mein Schlüsselbein war ja gebrochen. Das war die schönste Zeit meines Lebens. Und es war wirklich eine schöne Zeit, also bis auf die furchtbaren Schmerzen und die Einschränkungen und ich wusste, ob das alles so klappt. Aber jetzt muss die ja bald wieder raus, habe ich ganz vergessen. Oh, die Platte muss raus. Und das, und da haben alle gesagt, mach das im Winter, mach das im Winter. Nein, ich will das im Sommer machen. Na klar. Ich will das machen jetzt, wo, weil dann der Sommer, ich finde den unentspannt ein bisschen, weil man die ganze Zeit denkt, man sich, habe ich schon alles aus diesen tollen, langen, sonnigen Tagen gemacht.
Ich möchte diesen Gedanken nicht mehr haben. Ich möchte, und dann ist immer, hör auf dich, was willst du, gegen FOMO hilft, auf dich zu hören, auf deinen Körper zu hören, was brauchst du gerade, vielleicht brauchst du Ruhe, ja, und vielleicht brauche ich Ruhe, aber darauf höre ich ja nicht, ich will, ich will dann, denke, ja, ich habe den Tag nicht richtig genutzt. Und deswegen fände ich sowas Einschränkendes, wie zum Beispiel Krücken oder mal so eine Schiene oder mal so einen herrlichen Gips. So zwei Wochen raus. Leute müssen sich um mich kümmern. Das ist wirklich etwas, und das habe ich auch heute habe ich dann bei TikTok gesehen gesehen zeigt so ein heftling seine zelle und es gibt jeden tag essen jeden tag kochen sie für einen das ist eine ganz kleine zelle die ist jetzt nicht schön aber er hat darin bücher er macht da drin seinen sport dafür die bücher denn selber aussuchen ja klar okay er hat darin er hat offensichtlich ein handy sonst wäre das Video ja gar nicht möglich gewesen und das halt in so einem sehr geregelten Masse. Das heisst, du hast eine bestimmte Anzahl am Tag frei, da kannst du dann Sport machen, kannst was lesen, kannst Musik hören. Und wo ist dieses Gefängnis? Also wie kommt man da, also das klingt ja klasse, was kostet das so am Tag? Ja genau, und ich glaube, sich ja schon ein bisschen dafür, man muss sich da so für bewerben auf eine Art, weil alleine kriegst du es ja nicht. Nee, die sind ja, ich weiss auch nicht. Das kostet ja schon dann dem Staat eine gewisse Anzahl Geld, für die Häftlinge da zu sorgen. Ja. Jetzt können wir normalos da nicht rein. Und dann habe ich mich gefragt, was wäre die nächste Straftat, wo man am wenigsten Leute schadet,
so dass ich irgendwie mal so für ein Jahr, so ein halbes Jahr in den Knast.
Ich finde das nicht so schlecht.
Aber da ist ja die Frage, wann, ne? Wahrscheinlich so Grabraub oder sowas.
Also ich bin jetzt gerade bei Tuna nicht am Hut, aber ich würde sagen, Störung der Totenruhe.
Also ich glaube, so auf einen Friedhof und einen Grab ausbuddeln. Es gibt ein paar Ebenen, in denen man das denken muss, glaube ich. Wem schadet man mit seinem Verhalten der Straftat am wenigsten? Ja, den Toten. Das ist ja erstmal nicht so wild. So, und wann kriegt man, bei welcher Straftat kriegt man am wenigsten aufs Maul? Ja. Im Gefängnis. Ja. Also alle wissen, bei schlimmen Delikten werden die Leute da auch schon mal ordentlich hingerichtet, zugerichtet.
Ja.
Was so eine kleine Silbe machen kann mit dem Wort.
So, die Störung der Totenruhe ist mit einer Geldstrafe oder einer Freiheitsstrafe von bis zu drei Jahren bedroht.
Das gefällt mir, bis zu drei Jahren.
Bis zu drei Jahren, das heisst, wenn du jetzt keine besonders schwere Störung der Tottenruhe an die frage ist halt nur welches welches grab willst du schenden also willst du musst natürlich entweder einen wieso schenden störung der totenruhe kann ja auch schon sein ich setze mich nachts immer auf dem grab ja ja weiß ich nicht glaube für eine freiheitsstrafe muss da schon mehr passieren. Da musst du die Schaufel schon auspacken.
Okay.
Da musst du die Schaufel schon auspacken und ein bisschen graben und dann, glaube ich, wenn du erwischt wirst. Also du, klar kann man sagen, wenn die Familie das mitkriegt oder so, das ist natürlich dann schon, gibt es Geschädigte. Aber ich würde sagen, wenn Verbrechen, dann eher an den Toten. Weil, also ich weiss nicht, ob du an Geister glaubst. Nein. Ah, super, perfekt, Herr Tietze, dann haben wir genau die richtige Straftat für Sie. Allerdings muss man sagen, es gibt Fälle von Menschen, die im Gefängnis waren mit Störung der Totenruhe und die dann tatsächlich merkwürdige Dinge mit Blut an die Wand geschrieben haben und irgendwie sich selbst die Augen ausgekratzt haben und sich an ihrem eigenen Darm dann letzten Endes erhängt haben, aber das sind Einzelfälle.
Also wenn Sie jetzt konkret sagen, Sie glauben nicht an Geister, glauben Sie an Flüche, an Omen, an Omen ja, an Gule, Untote im weitesten Sinne, Gule, Zombies, Und Tote nicht.
Aber Ghoule, okay.
Ghoule und Omen.
Ghoule, Banshees, Nekromanten, das was in Gargoyles, sowas in der Richtung, Gargoyles wiederum.
Dann mache ich jetzt mal eine Liste auf.
Also, sie haben gesagt, Ghoule, Gargoyles, aber keine Banshees, keine Geister.
Omen.
Keine Banshees, keine Geister, keine Poltergeister.
Vampire, Mumien, Mumien, ja, also lebende Mumien? Oder also die, ja, also das ist jetzt, also Mumien im wissenschaftlichen Sinne, aber. Ich habe Angst vor Mumien im wissenschaftlichen Sinne. Okay, aber also Sie glauben jetzt nicht an untote Mumien, sondern normale Mumien. Okay, gut. Sie machen Winze, Sie sind nicht so schlecht. Danke. Was verstehen Sie genau unter einem Ghoul? Also jetzt auch im wissenschaftlichen Sinne ein ... Ja, diese Echsenart. Gut, ansonsten, was haben wir noch? Chimären, Manticore, Basilisken, Sirenen, oh ja, okay. ja okay also dann wassergeister mehrjungfrauen sirenen jetzt im klassischen wissenschaftlichen sitte normalen musikalischen okay alles klar und omen also damit meinen sie jetzt also das buch das buch das oben ach so king buch alles klar okay dann bleibt ja eigentlich nur noch gut wenn sie sagen guhle ist die echsenart vor Aber die ist langsam. Omen, ach so. Ja, ja, das Stephen King-Buch. Alles klar, okay, dann bleibt ja eigentlich nur noch, wenn Sie sagen, Gule ist die Echsenart, vor der Sie Angst haben, Omen ist das Buch. Ja. Und das dritte, wovor Sie Angst hatten, waren Gargoyles. War Gargoyles. Ja, ja, ja. Und damit meinen Sie die Spinne. Die Spinne. Okay, dann mache ich die Liste wieder zu, dann haben wir es doch, Sie glauben nicht an übernatürliche Dinge. Ach so, nee. Ach so, gut, so. So, dann ideal für Sie Störung der Totenruhe. Alles klar, vielen Dank. Wiederhören. Und dann aber, also, wird einberechnet bei Störungen der Totenruhe, wie wichtig der Tote ist, die Tote ist? Ja. Also ungenommen, jetzt in Köln gibt es ja auch den Meladenfriede, da sind viele berühmte Menschen drauf. Warte mal, ist jetzt nicht dieses Freud-Denkmal. Geschändigt worden. Das ist, glaube ich, gerade geschändet worden. Es gibt ein Denkmal, das gerade geschändet wurde, wo jemand draufgeschrieben hat, pervers. Boah, da hat das wirklich dem Freud gegeben. Wirklich? In Wien oder wo? Ja, in Wien. Also ich glaube, es ist nicht das Grab, sondern nur ein Denkmal. Aber ich weiss nicht, ob das als Störung der Totenruhe gilt, wenn du das Denkmal... Pervers. Das Schwein, das Schweige. Das habe ich nicht ganz verstanden. Ah, okay, also, es ist ein Stein, will ich eine Art Grabsteinartiges, aber vielleicht ein Denkmal von Sigmund Freund, da steht drauf, die Stimme des, weiss ich nicht, die Stimme des was ist leise? Ich kann das nicht lesen. Die Stimme des Intellekts ist leise. Aber das ist jetzt ein Zitat. Das ist jetzt ein Zitat. Das ist auch der Name der Folge. Die Stimme des Intellekts ist leise. Ja. So, aber jetzt. Aber das ganze Zitat lautet, die Stimme des Intellekts ist leise, aber sie ruht nicht, ehe sie sich Gehör verschafft.
Wichtig eigentlich, das sollte man nicht abkürzen.
Aber hier wurde es abgekürzt zu, die Stimme des Intellekts ist leise.
So, und jetzt hat der Grabschänder, der Schönen dieses Denkmals, gedacht, er streicht das durch, fett, die Stimme des Intellekts, das Schweige.
Steht der jetzt?
So der neue Satz, der dadurch entsteht, ist, das Schweigen ist leise. Und unter dem Namen Simon Freud hat er noch Pervert oder pervers? Pervert. Pervert geschrieben. Ja. Merkwürdige Schändung. Also ich weiß nicht, ob das, ich weiß nicht, ob du es warst oder nicht. ich will jetzt gar nicht irgendwie den Fingerzeig hier gross machen, aber. Was ich meinte, was ich glaube, was derjenige meint, ist zu sagen, niemand spricht darüber, dass er ein perverses Schwein gewesen sein könnte. Ach so, und deswegen sagst du es ist ja, gibt ja schon Kritikpunkte an Freud. Ah, ich verstehe. Also das Schweigen zu Freud ist leise, das Schweigen sollte ohrenbetäumend laut sein. Ja, da hat er fast nicht gereicht. Ähm, okay, alles klar. Gut, ich weiss nicht, was das an Strafe wäre, ob es da für Freiheitsstrafe gibt, weiss ich nicht, das hat ja irgendwie Traditionen. Für mich sieht das aus wie Geldstrafe, also das ist ja Geldstrafe, Graffiti-Gedöns. Ja, Vandalismus. Genau, vielleicht könnt ihr uns da helfen, ich möchte gerne so ein Jahr lang im Knast, das darf auch nicht nachhaltig meine Karriere leben oder wie auch immer beeinflussen, also ich habe jetzt keine Lust zum Beispiel deswegen den Podcast nicht mehr machen zu können. Nee, das kriegen wir hin. Bei Grabständung ist es ein seltsam. Störende Totenruhe, ich glaube, da wirst du auch jetzt nicht irgendwie dann blöd angemacht im Gefängnis, glaube ich. Also ich weiss nicht, ob es das wirklich gibt oder ob der Datenschutz da greift. Kannibalismus vielleicht? Weiss ich nicht. Weil du magst deinen kleinen Finger nicht, hast du gerade mehrmals gesagt. Genau, ich würde ihn eigentlich gerne loswerden, das Problem ist ...
Moment, aber du meinst, du könntest ihn abbeissen und dann einfach verzehren, meinen kleinen Finger.
Ja, also ich will ihn nicht abbeissen, das kriegen Menschen jetzt hier auch gar nicht unbedingt hin, aber du müsstest ihn vielleicht abmachen und dann muss ich das halt, wirklich sind ganz, ganz kleine Stücke unbemerkt. Ist es dann noch, ist es dann noch, ja, mhm. Würdest du ihn zubereiten, also würdest du dann noch ein bisschen Rosmarin noch anbraten, irgendwie schön resch, schön knusprig braten? Du vergisst, dass ich keine kandibalistischen Züge habe oder Gelüste habe. Ich will das einfach nur, ich will einfach nur ein Jahr lang mal da sitzen. Aber ich habe das Gefühl, bei Kannibalismus ist die öffentliche Wahrnehmung gleich so anders. Ich bin nicht so gestört, dass man dann vielleicht nicht unbedingt sein Leben weiterführen kann. Verstehe ich. Was ich aber bei Gesetzen immer ganz interessant finde, ist, dass der Versuch ja auch strafbar ist. Das heißt, wenn du jetzt sagst, ich will nur die Strafe, aber gar keine Straftat begehen, wäre doch glaube ich... Fühlt wie bei den Schauspiel auf. Es war eigentlich ideal, wenn du etwas versuchst. Also dann musst du, all keine Ahnung, du wirst dann irgendwie angehalten von der Polizei, auf dem Weg zum Friedhof, mit Schaufel im Kofferraum, mit einer Karte des Friedhofs, wo ein Grab mit einem grossen roten X markiert ist.
Und dann wirst du verurteilt.
Grabständung, Anfänger, genau, und Handschuhe und irgendwie so und einen grossen Beutel, wo die Erde reinkommt oder wo die Beute reinkommt.
Und dann sagt die Polizei, hier liegt offensichtlich eine versuchte Störung der Totenruhe vor.
Man weiss ja natürlich nicht, wie schwer es ist, aber dann könntest du tatsächlich ein Verbrechen begehen, ohne dass was Schlimmes passiert.
Also du musst eine Straftat versuchen.
Ich weiss nicht, ob der Versuch genauso schwer bestraft wird.
Nein, das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Na, weiss ich nicht.
Wirklich?
Versuchter Mord und Mord ist, glaube ich, das Gleiche, oder?
Meinst du wirklich?
Ja, ich glaube schon. Aber es ist halt die Frage, wie schwer es bestraft wird. Aber ich hätte ja noch einen Rückzug machen können. Ja. Also ich sag mal, da wird die Tür aufgemacht und dann merke ich in dem Moment, ich hole aus mit der stumpfen, mit dem im Salon bei Reverend Grün, ich hole aus mit dem Kerzenständer und in dem Moment merke ich, ich gucke mir die Augen und Menschlichkeit, erbarme dich.
Naja, aber du hattest ja ein klares Motiv, du hättest ja das Erbe bekommen, weil ja, in deiner Gesässtasche steckte ja der Anwaltsbrief, dass das Erbe gewechselt wurde, das ist ja Indiz zwei. Das Motiv kann ja nicht für die Urteilssprechung relevant sein. Naja, aber es ist natürlich schon, es lässt vermuten, dass du das durchgezogen hättest. Aber gut, das muss dann natürlich dein billiger Anwalt, der billigste Anwalt. Discount-Anwalt. Das ist ja das Problem. Wenn du ja wirklich ins Gefängnis willst, dann brauchst du ja einen richtig schlechten Anwalt. Ja, ja. Weil ansonsten bockst sich der Anwalt raus und sagt, zwinker, zwinker, Herr Tietze. Nee, aber ich möchte ja nicht fünf Jahre drin sitzen. Das ist ja wirklich, das ist wirklich mir wichtig. Das ist wirklich eine Gratwanderung. Also guckt mal, wir haben bestimmt Experten im Chat, im Kommentarspalte. Aber ich würde sagen, ein versuchtes Verbrechen, versuchte Störung der Totenruhe ist, glaube ich, gut. Super. Alles klar, dann ja. Und ich habe letztens, ich bin ja Sammler von Gründen, warum ICEs zu verspätet sind. Es gibt ja ganz illustre verschiedene Gründe. Und ich würde gerne mal die komplette Liste sehen, ehrlich gesagt,
weil das wird ja in der App angezeigt, das wird
ja eine vorprogrammierte Liste sein und dann
einfach nur angeixt, was
es ist. Und letztens hatte ich, was das hatte ich noch
nie, Vandalismus. Hat mir gut
gefallen, Vandalismus, will ich
die Vorstellung, dass jemand einfach so sauer ist auf
die deutsche Bahn, dass er mit einer Axt
die Gleise kaputt haut oder das Signal
zerstört, einfach in völliger gerechter Wut, einfach wirbelnd um sich schlägt und alles kaputt haut. Siehst du, da hätte ich jetzt gedacht, das fällt unter den Punkt Menschen im Gleis. Ja, guter Punkt. Kann aber, ja, kann sein. Das kann aber natürlich auch immer so ein Euphemismus für Suizid sein, aber jetzt frage ich mich, also weil es sind ja auch Menschen im Gleis mit einer Axt.
Kommt drauf an, wenn du mit einem Bogen oder einer Schleuder oder einer Armbrust, Balliste im weitesten Sinne. In dem weitesten Sinne ballistischen Sinne. Einem bullistischen Schussgerät römischer Machart, wie man sie zum Beispiel auf römischen Tiremen gefunden hat, die damals im Asyrischen Krieg relativ erfolgreich eingesetzt wurden. So, ich fahr mit meiner Tireme und meine Tireme mit mir. Und damit schießt sie jetzt aus, naja, was hat das für eine Reichweite, 100, 200 Meter wird das schon präzise schießen können, kommt auf die Machart an. Makedonische waren dann natürlich teilweise noch nicht so weit entwickelt. Trotzdem könntest du natürlich das Signal abfeuern, ohne dich selbst ins Gleis zu begeben. Jetzt mal nur theoretisch.
Dann war ich aber im Zug und dann dachte ich mir, okay, Vandalismus wird wahrscheinlich ein Grund sein, da wird sich der Zug solidarisch verbünden und sagen, ja, Vandalismus, da kann man nichts machen.
In der Durchsage im ICE wurde der Strafbestand plötzlich aber geändert. In Von Vandalismus zu Da hat jemand Kabel geklaut, was ja für mich nicht Vandalismus ist. Vandalismus ist ja ein zielloses, zerstörerischer Akt ohne Eigennutzen. Ja, ja, ja, Eigennutzen. Aber Diebstahl ist ja was ganz anderes. Das heisst, da hat jemand kabel geklaut für mich absolut fantastisches verbrechen einfach ich weiss nicht wie man das macht weil also welche kabel stehen die nicht unter strom kann man sich dann nicht massiv verletzen die man sich da so abmacht kannst du dann anders gebrauchen oder verkaufen also für welche anderen zwecke sind denn die kabel welche Zwecke sind denn die Kabel? Welche Kabel waren das denn? Vor allem, ich stelle mir vor, einer steht in Köln, der anderen Hagen. Dann sind die per Walkie-Talkie verbunden. Cut jetzt das Kabel, over. Ich habe das nicht verstanden nochmal. Schneid jetzt das Kabel ab, over. Ja, Black Mamba, over. Verstanden, over. Hallo? Ist das Kabel schon abgeschnitten, over? Ach so, nein, noch nicht, noch nicht, ich war noch mit Walkie-Talkie-Kram beschäftigt, over. Jetzt abgeschnitten, over. Okay, dann ist in Hagen abgeschnitten und in Köln fängt jemand an zu ziehen und zieht das komplette Oberleitungskabel von Hagen ach so, ja, stimmt, um um den Unterarm. Und dann zieht man das komplett raus und dann fährt der erste Zug des Tages so dü dü dü dü dü dü dü dü dü. Ah, ah, Lieselotte, ein neuer Tag als Bahnschaffner. Ah, ich bring die Leute dorthin, wo sie hinfahren wollen. Gestern war alles unpünktlich, aber heute habe ich ein gutes Gefühl. Schatz, heute willst du deinen Zug endlich mal pünktlich ans Ziel bringen. Ich habe ein gutes Gefühl. Schatz, du schaffst das. Los geht's! Diese Lotte. Du bist aber, ich glaube, ich habe noch fünf Minuten Zeit. Okay, wir cutten fünf Minuten. Dann sitzt er im Cockpit und sagt, so, die bringe ich jetzt an ihr Ziel. Greift den Hebel, legt ihn nach vorne um. Ja, Kabel durch. Kabel durch. Ja. Und was machst du dann? Ja, was machst du dann? Dann stehst du erst mal da. Also das ist ja richtig perfide, da das Kabel mitzunehmen.
Aber ich habe tatsächlich, muss ich sagen, und ich will es hier niemanden irgendwie in die Bredouille bringen, ein Kumpel von mir sammelt tatsächlich Kupfer und ist sowas wie ein Kupferhändler. Nee, nicht Dieb, aber der sagt immer, ich habe mir jetzt einen Kabelschneider gekauft, also so ein Gerät, wo du so ein Kabel reinsteckst und auf der anderen Seite kommt nur der Draht im Inneren des Kabels raus, also so ein Enthüller. So was habe ich auch, ein Enthüller. Wozu hast du denn sowas, ey? Sag mir nicht, du hattest eine Kupferphase, du hattest eine Bronzephase, eine Kupferphase, Eisenphase. Nee, ich hatte tatsächlich eine Heimwerkerphase und dafür musste ich, habe ich Lampen umgeschaltet bei mir. Da habe ich aber erzählt, ich war eine Haustechnik dran. Und dann musstest du die Kabel immer aufmachen, damit du die neu verbinden kannst. Genau, und da wollte ich etwas neu verbinden und dann muss ich die aufmachen. Das ist ein Kauf, den ich so nie beabsichtigt hatte. Ich hatte sogar explizit die Angst, dass ich dieses Gerät brauchen würde für mein Vorhaben. Und dann brauchte ich es noch. Wollte ich es nicht haben, aber jetzt habe ich so ein Gerät. Okay. So. Aber wo warst du denn vor drei Tagen? Als ich mit dem ICE gefahren bin. Wo warst du denn? Hast du Naja, weil Stefan, es werden aktuelle Kabeldiebe gesucht, du besitzt so einen Kabelentkerner und du hast kein Alibi. Aber die Bahn hat ja genug. Auf Kabeldiebstahl steht Freiheitsstrafe von bis zu einem Jahr. Naja, weiß ich. Ich habe richtig Bock auf Gefängnis von einem Jahr. Du hast ja so einen riesigen Rucksack dabei auch. Ja, kannst du haben. Das sieht ganz schön schwer aus. Du spendest das Kupfer.
Du legst, der Kupferdieb wurde später gefasst, aber überraschenderweise hat man vor einem Kindergarten 16 Tonnen Kupfer gefunden mit einem Schild für die Kinder. Leider hat es die Fluchtwege und die Feuerwehrzufuhr versperrt, weshalb das Feuer, was da an dem Tag leider ausgebrochen ist, ein anderer Vandalismus, weil Florenti wollte auch in den Knast. Die Kinder, die in die Notaufnahme kamen, konnten leider nicht in Kernspintomographen, weil da gerade der Sarkophag tut ja nicht Arm uns wahr, weswegen leider 60 Kinder zugrunde gegangen sind. Am Anfang der Folge gesagt, alles hängt zusammen, alles ist ein Kreis, alles ist ein großer Kreis, the circle of crime. Deswegen nehmt eure Sarkoferge aus den Kernschwemtemographen raus. Ja, raus damit, Leute, ihr verstopfen das die ganze Zeit. Ja. Aber anscheinend ist Kupfer viel wert, also wenn das Leute wirklich zur Kriminalität anstiftet. Er, oh mein, was heißt, er sammelt Kupfer? Dein Freund sammelt Kupfer. Er sagt immer, schmeißt die Sachen nicht weg, gibt sie mir, so Kabel, alte Elektronik-Sachen und dann zieht er da das Kupfer und was auch andere, jede Metalle raus und dann hat er immer den Kupfer. Dein Freund sammelt Kupfer. Er sagt immer, schmeiss die Sache nicht weg, gibt sie mir, so Kabel, alte Elektronik-Sachen und dann zieht er da das Kupfer und was auch andere, jede Metalle raus und dann hat er immer den Kupfer-Kurs im Blick.
Ja, er sammelt, das ist mir, Wörter sind mir schon wichtig, also er sammelt nicht Kupfer, er verkauft Kupfer.
Er handelt mit Kupfer auf jeden Fall.
Er verscherbelt Kupfer.
Ich glaube, der nimmt, also wenn der da so einen Kupferzaun sieht irgendwo, dann holt der mal seine Zange raus. Hol den mit. Warum nicht? Naja, weil das nicht ihm gehört. Er liegt doch rum. Liegt doch rum. Ja. So ein bisschen wie diese Metalldetektor-Leute so. Ja, aber das ist Finders Keepers. Finders Keepers. Aber schon ein komisches Hobby auch, oder? Das verstehe ich. Ich muss auch sagen, dass die Leute oft suspekt sind. Die wirken auch oft schlecht gelaunt und so. Und irgendwann, das finde ich auch immer so lustig, bei Hobbys entwickelt sich ja erst so eine Ich fange es neu an, man gibt sich noch Mühe, man ist irgendwie noch sehr vorsichtig und noch nicht so geschickt. Aber irgendwann, das geht ja relativ schnell, jedem wie viele stunden du dieses hobby ausfüllst irgendwann wird es so super nonchalant du machst währenddessen auch andere dinge und dann kommen ja immer nachts dann diese am strand als ich im urlaub in der ostsee immer war kann man abends oft diese leute mit metalldetektoren die ihre so kopfhörer im ohr hatten und dann so super grimmig und dann so nach Schätzen gesucht haben.
Nach Münzen wahrscheinlich einfach. Ja, aber das ist ja nicht das Bild, was du von Schatzsuchern hast. Nee, gar nicht. Sondern aber die waren dann so sehr genervt. Hör die Sackern, werfen sie auch so lustlos wieder weg einfach und finden sie am nächsten Tag wieder. Ja. Wie dumm ist das denn eigentlich? Wie finden die so krasse Sachen, so alte Piratenmünzen und es kommt halt dann in deren Sack zu den anderen 50 und da ist so wenig Lust und Leben im Gesicht mehr.
Vor allem, ich habe nur mal so eine Compilation gesehen von so einem Metalldetektorsucher und Passanten, die ihn angepöbelt haben, von wegen, ja, sie dürfen wir nicht sein, das ist mein Acker, so und der immer so, ja, schleich dich, also, das heißt, er streitet sich den ganzen Tag einfach mit Leuten. Oh, wir können es jetzt also auch biografisch zuordnen, wo das Ganze gespielt hat. Der streitet sich einfach den ganzen Tag mit Leuten, ist das aber legal, dass sie das suchen, ja, lass mich ruhig, du Kaspar, du, und einfach, und ich so, das ist deine Compilation, so, ich meine, du kommst unfassbar unsupartig dabei weg, aber ich glaube, irgendwann hast du aber nichts zu verlieren. Was er hochgeladen hat. Ja, ja, ja, und wo der einfach wirklich auch null argumentiert hat oder rechtlich hier so ist die Situation, sondern einfach zurückgepöbelt hat. Wahrscheinlich das erste Jahr sagst du nein, nein, öffentliche Gebiete und so und man darf und da darf man sich bewegen und whatever. Aber irgendwann so, hab du kein, schweißt dich! Einfach so, wenn das Argumentieren auch nichts mehr hilft. Irgendwann gibst du es auch. Ja, das meine ich. Also irgendwann, achtet mal selbst drauf, wenn euer Hobby irgendwann so sehr zum Teil eures Lebens wird, dass ihr diesen grimmigen Blick dabei bekommt und so glasige Augen und so anfangt so rumzupöbeln, weil ihr das schon zu oft gehört habt, dass euer Hobby da nicht auszuführen ist, dann wäre es vielleicht Zeit für ein neues Hobby. Ich glaube, man kann Hobbys so lange betreiben, dass sie keinen Spaß mehr machen, sondern dass sie einfach nur noch Pflicht und Teil des Lebens sind. In der Videospielwelt ganz bekannt, dass Leute kompetitive Spiele spielen, den ganzen Tag wütend sind, ihre Teammates anschreien und man sich denkt, warum machst du das überhaupt noch? Ich rede mit mir selbst. Ja, ich kenne es von Golf, also das bei Larry David oder sowas, die dann Golf spielen und sich immer so hassen, weil das so schlecht läuft. Und ich glaube, genau so kann ich mir das vorstellen. Also die Leute, das ist auch ein Brecht, die Frage, warum hörst du nicht einfach auf damit? Das ist aber so, das wird nicht zugelassen, dieses Argument immer, als Teil des Streits. Wie hart ist ein Golfball ungefähr? Stell dir einen Puck vom Eishockey vor, härter als das. Wow, okay, das ist schon hart.
Jetzt habe ich das Gefühl, du hast es nicht genau verstanden.
Jetzt mal unter uns. Also ich weiß, ich bin kein Sportler und so, aber könnte man nicht zum Beispiel, wenn du statt einem Golfballen einen Flummi nimmst? Weiter schlagen. Fliegt der nicht weiter. Aber geht es nicht darum, genau diesen Gegenstand, den alle anderen auch haben, halt schneller, besser, weiter zu schlagen, weniger Schläge zu brauchen als der die Kontrahentin? Ich dachte mir, dass bei Olympia so jede Sportart wäre cooler mit Flummis. So Tennis, nimm Flummi, Golf, Flummi, Polo, Flummi, Basketball, nimm noch einen richtig, richtig hart bounzigen Ball. Sind nicht die besten Sportarten die perfekt austarierten?
Also... Flummi, Basketball, nimm doch einen richtig, richtig hart bounzigen Ball. Sind nicht die besten Sportarten die perfekt austarierten?
Also wo genau das Feld im richtigen Verhältnis zu der Härte des Balles. Ach du meinst, dann müsste man den Tennisplatz fünfmal so gross machen mit Flummi bei der ...
Ey, wenn der Tennisball nur ein bisschen irgendwie weniger krass aufgepumpt wäre, glaube ich, ist es nicht mehr so ein schönes Spiel. Das kann sein, das kann sein. Der Ton ist so, ja, ja. Blump, Blump, Blump, so ein fragendes, jetzt Anakonikova gegen Serena Williams. Blump, Quiet, please, Fifty Love, Fifty Love, Serifone, Anakonikova, Blump, Blump, R, von, Hasnagrkoper.
Wir sind beide ans Limit gegangen, einfach. Wir müssen uns kurz würgen. Dieser Gag wurde Ihnen präsentiert von Dolodo Bendan.
Macht's gut, ich wünsche euch eine ganz schöne Woche, haut rein, seid sportlich, viel Spaß, haut rein, wir heben ab, wir klappen, wir klappen die Laderampe hoch, wir klappen die Tische hoch, alles aufgeräumt, wir hinterlassen es so, wie wir es vorgefunden haben. Hast du eigentlich mal meine, du hast nicht so eine Markise gesagt, die ich vorhin ans Ufo gebaut habe. Ja, ich dachte, aber kannst du mich fragen, bevor du sowas installiert, weil der Luftwiderstand
das flattert die ganze Zeit. Wir sind beide der gleich
wichtiger Teil des Podcast-Ufos, warum soll ich
keine einfach rumbauen? Ja, aber du hast es jetzt nicht eingeräumt, du hast es nicht eingeräumt.
Du kannst auch rumbauen, du machst halt nie was.
Ja, weil ich denke, das ist eine Gemeinschaftsentscheidung.
Kannst du nicht was machen, du machst es eh nie.
Können wir die Klimaanlage ein bisschen?
Nee.
Okay, dann bis nächste Woche, Macht's gut. Tschüss.
Ciao.
Ach so, it's die Grillsoßen. Mindestens 10 Millionen Euro im Jackpot, Ziehungen dienstags und freitags.
Das Leben könnte so Jackpot sein, mit Eurojackpot.
Jetzt in deiner Annahmestelle, Infos auf eurojackpot.de.
In Deutschland lizenzierte Anbieter, Spielteilnahme ab 18, Glücksspiel kann süchtig machen, Infos und Hilfe unter checkdeinspiel.de, Jackpot-Chance 1 zu 140 Millionen.